and our speaker today
is victor babst victor is a theoretical
physicist by training
having obtained his phd from the call
normal in paris
where he looked at quantum disorder
systems and their relations to quantum
computing
after a postdoc in frankfurt on the
mathematics of phase transitions hidden
joined google deep mind
five years ago where he has worked since
on data efficient reinforcement learning
transfer learning and graph networks
his talk today combines the physics
aspects and the machine learning aspects
he's going to tell us what graph
networks can teach us about phase
transitions
and glasses so victor please whenever
you're ready
thank you thank you philip for the
invitation and for the introduction
uh so yes so this this talk is about
this work that uh
i did in the last year i mean
yeah last two years i did mine with in
particular
my colleagues that i want to mention
thomas keg and yeshka krabska babinska
and craig donner
uh and also help for a bunch of other
people
uh deepman and google and so this work
was about
understanding how much neural networks
can tell us about
glass glassy systems and so first i want
to start
this presentation by explaining what the
glass transition is because i assume
some of you may know what it is and so
for some some others it might be
you might be less familiar with it and i
want to show you how big just it is
so what is a glass a glass but simply
it's just a liquid that has stop
flooring so if you look at the structure
on these three
schematics you have on the left crystal
and
on the right or liquid it's very clear
what the difference is that the liquid
is disordered
and if you look at a glass uh you know
again a schematic view it looks
just like a liquid so you can't see the
difference uh if you just look at
the structure but obviously
the the dynamics is very different in a
glass if you think about you know a
piece of uh structural glass in your
horse it's something that doesn't move
and that
has a rigid response to uh to pressure
for instance
and um the glass transition is not
something which is you know which is
sharply defined
uh as a usual phase transition but it's
defined experimentally
as to when the viscosity has increased
by a 14 or
14 order of magnitudes um the viscosity
being
some measure of you know how fast does
the liquid flow and this happens over a
small change of temperature so you
change the
temperature by 30 or less and you have
this you know huge
change in the some of the the response
parameters of the system
and so what are the questions that we
are asking here so so and why is it an
interesting problem
um so one question is why why does it
slow down so dramatically
uh and in particular the transition is
is non-arrhenius in the sense it's
faster than exponential in the inverse
temperature
um and what is going at the mixed quick
level that causes the slowdown so as i
said before you know if you take a navy
view then you don't see that you don't
really see a difference between a glass
and a liquid at the microscopic level so
can you find structural markers of this
transition
uh another way to to look at this
problem is to think in terms more of
microstate so if you if you're used to
like the physics of phase transition and
then you would ask
is there something happening at the
level of these states
maybe at the local minima of the of the
free energy that explains
uh this change of behavior in the glass
and finally one of the one of the
interesting question is how does the
dynamics unfold so we've said that the
dynamics was getting much slower
but can we understand you know how the
glass starts moving when it starts
moving and
on this picture for instance you this is
a picture of the
um i think in the 2d glass of the it's
it's origin it is in the dynamics but
you can see you know the red particles
are
those that are moving more than the blue
ones and you can see that you have these
domains of you know
regions that start to move together in a
coordinated manner
and can we characterize these
heterogeneities and can they help us
understand
the slowdown in the glass dynamics
so why why do i care about this problem
first it's a fundamental theoretical
question
uh the uh from the nobel prize
video on the sunset said you know in the
famous statement that this was the
deepest and most interesting unsolved
problem inside
theory and the nature of the glass and
the class transition
and it occurs in a wide range of systems
and i'll try to give a quick overview
now so the first example example uh
the most in a natural one and one i
already mentioned is uh
is molecular glass structural glass so
this is something that human have been
doing for a long time uh
you know two thousands here two thousand
years before crust christ
and um in which case that you know what
you normally
have in mind with glass it's just a
glass of that silica and it's not
something which is naturally occurring
on earth so
glass can form a special condition of
pressure like when you have a very high
pressure on the material
and you have you know several sources of
natural glass
and can form with many materials so um
one fun fact maybe is that uh if you
look at water in the universe the most
common form of water
the most common structure of water is is
is actually some
glass amorphous eyes so not the crystal
ice but the amorphous ice
and for instance that's what uh europa
ladies man of jupiter is made of
uh mostly um another example of class
transition is eye running so um
i mean yeah some of those things i just
learned you know when preparing this
presentation and trying to explain
people what the classroom
transition was about but yeah i think
those are kind of interesting to give an
idea of you know
how common this transition is uh so
ironing
is a glass transition of the the polymer
and
so basically what happens is that when
you hit the polymer you get above the
glass transition so
the fabric becomes uh soft you know okay
kind of it's not a liquid but it has
this property of being
um you know having a fast dynamic and so
you can impose
a pressure on it with the iron and then
when when it cools down
you go through this glass transition and
stops moving
and the movement of the polymer chains
is arrested
a third example uh is jamming
um so in jamming you don't have really a
notion of temperature anymore so this is
describing systems of hot particles and
interaction
uh you can think of sound for instance
and uh there are the control parameters
so as i said it's not the temperature
anymore but this is the pressure
and so as you increase the density so as
you increase the density the
the viscosity increases extremely
quickly and that's what happens for
instance if you pull the sand castle and
you pack it together you see the you
know the the sun stop stops flowing
uh another you know domain where people
have tried to connect
uh the phenomenology with glasses are
always jamming is traffic jams for
instance so this kind of collective
behaviors where
you can have this this first transition
between the phase which is very fluid an
effect which is completely arrested when
you change you know the density by
a little a small amount
um and i think this was a nice video
illustrating jamming where
uh so this uh this is in conor uh
creative mission labs and
they were creating some some robots with
uh coffee beans and so you would
yeah so this is a single gaming first
transition so you put the bins
in this balloon and then the robot will
be able to change
the density just by a tiny bit and that
will make the
you'll see the handle completely rigid
and you should see it grab
objects
so yeah that's an illustration of you
know how far
like the the robot is changing i think
that the density by five the volume of
the balloon by five percent of less but
then the you know the solid the response
is completely drastic
let's move to another illustration so
people have looked for a glass
transition in in biology and uh
in particular in cell migration so
yeah i mean i'm not you know i'm not
going to pretend to be to understand
these things very deeply but
basically you observe different uh
states of biological tissues and i think
you know one appealing aspect of the
glass transition is the fact that you
have this control parameter that changes
um by by a small amount and then the
response which changes by a large amount
which is something that
you know is pretty appealing if you
think about modeling this kind of system
because you could imagine that
in the body you'd have you know some
control parameter that
that that you you don't want to change
it by order of magnitude of value you
want it to change it by a small value
and then you want to be heavier to
change a lot
which is something that could be
happening uh and could be relevant for
our brain development metastasis in
cancer so this is basically about the
organization of the cells and and
whether the cells
are are in the face which is fluid or
not also they'd like um
another example uh going more to
computer science is optimization
problems
so there the idea is that you look at
you know variables binary binary
variables with constraints
between them and and
if you do that and you know under some
you know
uh conditions uh on defining these
problems you
you you create you know you can create a
uh um
a statistical physic i mean uh uh
you know a system which is another goes
to a physical system
with the main difference being that you
i mean you've swapped the continuous
variable that you have in a class that
describe the position to binary
variables
but then you know if you do it in the
right way you kind of go from glasses to
spinning glasses which was
also an interesting area of physics in
the 80s
um and so so here the idea is basically
you have these variables and you had
constraints between them and you know
you had it's concerned at random and you
can control the density so the control
parameter is the density of constraints
which is you know related to how hard it
is so the more concern you had
you you add the less solutions you would
find but then what people found is that
they were you know
a very similar phenomenology um in these
problems between a regime where you know
when you have little concern it's easy
and then
as you add them you know at some point
you don't have a solution anymore but in
between these things you have a class
transition and this is where the
hardness of the problem also appears if
you try to solve it with an algorithm
um and so this has proven to be relevant
for consensus selection problem exam for
instance random set
of random sustainability um
and and on this uh progress also you
know more
like theoretical progress has been made
as well because this is a
problem which is simpler to to tackle
than the glass transition in three
dimensions because this is essentially
an infinite dimensional problem
so not everything is understood there
but you know the existence of a glass
transition is better understood
um and finally uh
as an extension to the previous point uh
it has been you know interesting
in seeing whether so so whether this
could also
apply to some of the machine learning
questions and in particular
so this paper was looking at the
training of neural networks in the
regime where you don't have many
parameters so where they are under
parameterized
uh and so you're trying to fit you know
the neural network is trying to fit
uh to some objective but it's uh that
doesn't have enough parameters so it's
it's kind of struggling to
to represent the constraints if you want
and so if you look at the so these two
plots were showing you know on the
uh on the left uh a glassy system uh so
so
glass and on the right uh the
the weight of the neural networks and
this this is measuring basically how
much the system is moving
some measure of the um and
and uh the colors should slow down to
the yellow yeah this plateau
where the things stopped moving and
basically what this was showing is that
you know you had potentially some
similar phenomenology between the two
um okay so
while the last slide was talking about
uh you know glasses and machine learning
this is like this talk has nothing to do
with that this is about machining
applied to glasses
rather than the opposite and in
particular this is about graph networks
or propensity prediction
so i first need to tell you what
propensity is
in what we're doing i'm not going to
spend a lot of time on the physical
system
and i'm going to describe it on this
slide so this is a we take basically you
know
the standard system to describe uh a
class
uh in a computer simulation or for
theoretical study
so the other thing i should say is of
course i mean because
as i described the glass on this one is
very ambiguous and there's there is this
belief you know from statistical physics
that
the precise details of the system don't
matter too much
you know as long as you are within
university class so as long as you have
short-run interactions between between
the particles
and some you know conditions some weak
conditions then you know it doesn't
really matter what you do so you can
just pick this canonical system
which is you know particle is a box with
a an energon's potential and
um the the i guess one of the details
that you need to have two types of
particles so this is why it's a mixture
because if you have only one type then
you know you have a crystal which is
easier to find and the system might
crystallize which is not what you want
so you put two types of particular
radius that don't go very well together
and then what we do so we can so there
is a notion of temperature you can
simulate the system at different
temperatures you can equilibrate it
and then you can run the dynamics of the
system starting from an equilibrium
configuration and so when you run the
dynamics of the system with molecular
dynamics
you have some randomness and so
i guess here the thinking is you know it
doesn't necessarily make sense to
predict exactly
uh how you get like what the so we want
to make
predictions on the future given the
starting state but you know because
there is randomness that might be
difficult
and so what we do instead is use this
propensity which is the mean
displacement of each particle under you
know different random velocities so you
start from a fixed configuration
and then you sample 30 initial
conditions for the velocities you unroll
your simulation 30 times
up to a given time in the future and
then you average how much each particle
has moved and that's a way to you know
smoothen out
the random fluctuations and just retain
you know the important information in
the information that can be more easily
predicted which is about you know this
particle is mobile and typically you
will move a lot
or this particle is really stuck in this
kind of initial configuration won't move
a lot whatever the
the the the random velocity
um what you see on these plots so the
top left panel is showing you uh the
plot of the propensity of the average
propensity as a fraction of the
temperature
and so the different colors are
different temperatures this is as a
function of time
so what you see on the red is the the
highest temperature and so there you
have
for short times the ballistic regime
where things move linearly so the
displacement is proportional to time
and then you go you start having
collisions then you have this inflection
and then you hide in the diffusive
regime where the slope goes from one to
one half
and this is because particles are
colliding together and this is a liquid
so this is the the you know the high
temperature regime which is not the one
that we are uh
that's that's relevant for the glass
transition and then as you lower the
temperature and you go to the blue
curves
so still looking at the top left figure
what you see is that this plateau which
appears where you know
this uh this propensity stops uh
increasing
and then at the end for the long terms
you always recover the diffusive regimen
and
this has to be like that the system is
diffusing over a long time but you have
this this intermediate phase between the
ballistic and the diffusive regime
where where the system is apparently not
moving
and this is so this is the regime that
we are interested in
in and where we want to make predictions
um and uh so the bottom left figure is a
measure of the length of this plateau if
you want
and what this shows you that as you
decrease the temperature you know the
length of this platter increases
and uh and this is the part that is you
know what with this curve that
you can fit with various flows and you
know what's the exact color that you
should use to fit this is an open
question but that's faster than an arrow
so that decreases
that increases very fast with
temperature um
which also means you can't simulate
systems you know at very low temperature
uh because because they they just become
impossible to equilibrate at least in
this setup
uh and so to summarize the results we
got we we so
so so our problem was this prediction of
starting from this for this
configuration can we predict the
configuration in the future and what we
will show is that you know we we
outperformed the pre-existing methods
and that also we could analyze the
working of our networks
and try to extract a green kardashian
links from it and i think that part is
interesting in in
you know when you think about applying
machine learning to physics problem
because this
goes be this tries to go beyond you know
a regression program or
classification problem and go to go into
you know can we interpret what the
networks are doing and can we
draw some insights from them um
so in terms of related work uh it had
been working on this uh
question and um
most of the work that had been done so
far was trying to do
to do some correlation again between you
know the the starting
configuration and how much the particle
would move but that was using simpler
techniques
that were based on heuristics so you
define features for each particle and
then you use
classifier and
um in in the future i'm also going to
compare to the traditional approaches
uh for solving the same problem so you
know obviously people in physics
uh had looked at whether they could find
good predictor of the dynamics you know
can you can you say whether particularly
we will be moving on not based on some
physics-based approaches so one
you know one one natural idea is to
reference
the potential energy so you could look
at whether you know particular has a
high energy and maybe it wants to relax
more so maybe it's going to move more so
that's the rough idea of the potential
energy method
and then you have you know more uh more
involved methods that still rely on the
energy function of the system and on
trying to understand you know what are
the modes of relaxation of the systems
and
can does this say something about how
much of the
the system access um
so one thing to say before you know
going to residents and uh
and our method is that you know this
when we compare to these traditional
methods i think we have to bear in mind
that
i mean these methods are bringing
something more than just a prediction
they're bringing you know some insight
into
the system because if you say i'm
proposing to use this particular you
know form for the relaxation
uh and i can trade correlates with with
the ground truth then you are you know
potentially putting you know that can
give way to a theory why the machine
if you have a machining black box um
you know under certain conditions you
can hope that it's going to be more
predictive so it's not about who's the
has the best predictive power but it's
also about you know
the trade-off between having a good
predictive poor and understanding what a
what a method tells you
um so let me talk about about uh graph
network and more generally relational
networks
um again i don't know how much you know
the audience is not familiar with us
i'll try to
remain at a relatively high level so
relational networks are networks that
use a relational inductive bias to
perform their computation
uh which means that they are performing
computation over
an explicit or implicit graph of objects
so this is to be
you know uh to to be compared find sense
with convolutional networks that would
operate on images
or uh you know um rnn or lstms that
would be operating or that would operate
on sequences
or you know perceptrons that will
operate on you know
non-structured inputs so so with
different networks operate on
objects and on potentially graph of
objects
and they try to model the relationships
between these objects
and they try to be entered they should
be invariant in particular
implementations of the nodes and
of the edges um and there is a family of
models
in in this there's a variety of models
in this family
and i'm not going to describe them here
but they are traders basically what i
just want to mention is that there are
trade-offs between you know how much
graph structure do you put in this model
so you can have them that that are very
implicit
where the models you know will just
should discover the edges by itself
basically so you
take you know these are the objects and
they should be invited under permutation
but that's all you say you don't specify
a graph
uh and you have methods that are more
expressive or you can really say
specify which interaction should be
present in the system and forces the
model to to
process them on these interactions and
so um
in the trailers also coming in terms of
you know which ones are easier to turn
which one
use more memory and so on and so forth
uh
and the more bias you put in the model
might mean that it also gets you know
uh harder to train and the model i'm
going to present in this talk
is on the right of this panel so it's
it's a more structured model and we
will see that the graph structure is
explicit so we are enforcing some graph
structure based on our you know bias
about the system
um in terms of you know previous
applications of these models to uh
physics and chemistry again
just want to give a few examples uh one
of them was
to apply them to molecules so graph
networks apply to molecules
and this is a paper from uh three years
ago where the authors showed that you
could
you know get gft levels
predictions for class of molecules by
doing a
message by doing message passing on a
molecular graph so you would encode
you would use the molecular graph uh as
defined by the the formula of a molecule
and you would pass it to a network the
network could do computational energies
of this molecule and it would recover
the predictions from dft
but much faster
you can also use these models for
simulation so this is a recent example
where these authors were simulating
the behavior of water so you start from
a
you know an unequivocal condition and
you just let the water relax
and the modernity are using is again a
graph network so this is
somewhat similar to what i'm going to
present now in the sense that the model
is relatively similar and it's also a
task about simulation
the energy mostly stops there and you
can see on this video again that the
results are relatively impressive so
this is comparing the ground shows with
the simulation i don't know which one is
which actually
um and then to also be so i mentioned in
the beginning of this talk that
um you know glasses starting from
structural glasses you know
could also be put in an energy with uh
with such uh with control and
satisfaction problem and first of all
systems and uh this is an example of the
so so
and i mentioned you know statisticality
problem so so these papers were an
example of a playing machining directly
to these problems so can we
use machine learning to solve you know
uh these ones are about i think
one is about csp and the other was about
uh statistically problems
and um so this was a you know some
inspiration for this work in terms of
saying you know okay can we do the same
thing but for our
physics system in three dimensions
rather than for this uh
satisfiability problems
so what is architecture and how do how
do we prepare
how do we predict propensity so
this schema is a rough summary of what
we do so we start from a three
dimensional input which is the position
of the particles in an equilibrated
system at a given temperature
so we have this box where we have about
four thousand particles in it
we equilibrate these particles and um
we take the so we take one in created
configuration and this gives us three
inputs
from which we create a graph input by
connecting particles within the
threshold
so we connect particles that are within
2c mass sigma being
the typical length of the interaction
between the particles
and so this gives us a graph and this is
a graph for each particle has worth
having 20 neighbors
um and um
so so so on this graph what are the
features so on the nodes
you have the type of the of the
particles if you remember i said that
you know you have to have two types of
particles for this to work and
in order not to get a crystal so on the
notes we just have the type
and on the edges we have the relative
just the
relative vector between the two
particles
um so the difference in x y z between a
you know particular i particularly and
and the edges are big directional so you
have one edge in each direction
and then this will be fed to a growth
network uh so i'm going to explain on
the next slide a bit more how this works
but this is a network as i said
which expects to take this graph as
input is going to make a computation
that's aware of the graph and it's going
to make you know
to update the features of these graphs
it's going to update the features which
are in the edges and on the nodes
and so in particular the output of this
network you have a number of it on each
node right
and then what we do is regress these
numbers to the true propensity
so starting from this 3d input if you
remember we also had run the study
simulations
for a given amount of time and so what
we do is take so we do this simulation
30 times
we stop them we have read how much each
particular has moved and that gives us
11 and then we try to
regress the output of our network which
is shown on the on the right there to
this quantity
how does the network operate so one step
of graph network propagation
is made of two steps so first for each
edge you look at an
adjacent node and you update the state
of an edge based on the two nodes which
it connects to and the previous state of
this edge
so so for a forgiven edge i take the
previous
state of this edge so it will start with
this 3d vector
but it will be updated to something
learned and i take the two nodes which
are you know
i just started at the end i concatenate
all these vectors i feed them to uh some
networks so
an mlp and that gives me a new vector
for this edge and then i can update a
node
so for each node what do i do i collect
the previous node state and then collect
all the edges
which are incoming into this node i sum
the embeddings
because there might be different number
of edges so i cannot just you know
and this needs to be environmental under
permutation so i have to reduce this so
i do a sum
and i fit that to an mlp and again this
gives me a new node state
and then so this update after i've done
these two updates what happens is that
you know each edge has a new state based
on the previous node states and it
should not
has a new state based on this edge state
and so if you think about it you can see
that when you do one step of this you
are propagating information distance one
so each node after one step of whether
just describe we'll know about its
neighbors
instead of its neighbors and so then if
you apply this network several times
uh and you could apply the same network
by different networks
um but in any case the information is
going to propagate in a graph
so you know if you apply the network
three times then you can show that each
node
starts to to be uh so the state of each
node will depend potentially of the set
of nodes that distance up to three from
it
all right and um
yeah and so in practice that's what we
do so in practice we have this graph
network that we apply several times
and you know the more we apply it the
more the information can propagate
in the graph um
so in terms of so yes i'm going to move
towards showing the results and so i i
want to define the time scale that we
look at
uh so as i alluded to before
um this is the um
so this is the curve of the displacement
uh or the propensity as a function of
time
and so as i i mean uh yeah this slide is
maybe not in the best place so you first
have this ballistic regime and at the
end it's deficient regime and we are
interested in this glacial regime which
is in between where things apparently
don't move
and okay so now let me show some results
uh so this is showing as a function of
time how much
uh you you can predict the quality of
the prediction basically so
we look at the correlation between the
predicted propensities for each particle
rests as the ground truth all right so
if you pre if you predict exactly the
right propensity then you get a score of
one
you should do a random prediction you
get the score of zero you could have
negative correlation
um and uh what you can show on the top
of this plot is that there's a gray area
so you can't actually
which one exactly because of this you
know you still have some randomness in
your labyrinth you only run 30
simulations
so you can't get beyond the fluctuations
of this number so that's why you know
actually the best you can do is this
gray
and um and the the solid dashed line is
the
typical time scale of the glass
relaxation so this is showing you know
the typical time scale that you care
about so this is the time scale which is
in the middle of this plateau
um okay and so on this plot the three
curves i'm showing are
um standard physics methods of potential
energy uh
d by water factorance and soft mods and
so you can see that they get some
positive correlation with the ground
truth
but it's that it's pretty weak um so
yeah i think that's understood there and
then this was so the green curve was the
method that was
previously proposed from the machine
learning literature so this svm which is
based on encrypted features
and you can see it performs you know
better than the previous methods
uh one advantage of the svm is that you
can do some analysis on it because it's
based on handcrafted videos so you know
it's relatively easy to figure out which
features matter and then you can you can
do
you can relatively easily introduce
something from it so it's not deep
learning
uh at the same time it's not you know
extremely powerful you can see that the
results are not
that much better than the the previous
uh physics test method
um and now this is the methods that we
tried so we tried uh in orange
standard conventional network i'm not
going to talk about that and in blue
this is a graph network
and you can see that you get quite a
substantial gain in performance there
compared to the previous methods a few
things to note on this curve you can see
on the very short times
you can see that the model the graph
network is capable of completely
computing the dynamics right
so the very short time is not
interesting for the physics and it's not
uh
you know it's not difficult it's not
supposed to be difficult neither because
you know each particle has moved only
a little bit within its cage so you know
that's something that you expect should
be computable but it's nice to see that
the method does it and can do it
and that's you know an indication of the
fact that this method is well suited to
describe physical systems basically
and the dynamics is well described by
these pairwise interactions that the
graph network
is representing um
and then you can see this you know this
disruption in performance and then
the performance increases again as the
time increases
which is something that um
yeah which is something which which is
uh you know
maybe was not completely expected and i
think it's an interesting observation
the fact that
as you increase the time scale the
predictive power of the system does not
diminish but i
actually increases um
and which which yeah which we would not
have
you know i mean we can make some
possible explanation but i don't think
we have a strong
reasoning for why why that's the case um
but there could be some i mean that
could be saying something about a
reduction in fluctuations
as the time increases um or the fact
that when you get closer to the
diffusive regime
you know a picture the prediction of
density becomes a bit easier because you
maybe you are
um yeah when you get closer to the
diffusive regime you know dynamics
should be better described in
intelligent density so that could be
another explanation
um and these are our uh propensity maps
that we obtain with our methods so on
the
first row you can see so again from left
to right you go from short times to
large times
so the the rightmost colon is a
diffusive regime
and the leftmost colon is a very short
times and then the glassy
uh like the interesting glassy regime is
the third column and the second column
is where it's the hardest format
to predict um so you can see the glassy
regime is the interim
is an intermediate between a regime
which is diffusive where you see the
kind of pattern that you might be used
to if you've looked at you know the heat
equation before
uh in a regime which is more
heterogeneous
and uh so the colon the first row is the
branches and you can see the second
layer or method is very close to the
crunches visually
and this is compared to what was the you
know the best physics method
i mean yeah the best experiment before
which is a soft mod which only works for
the second column so
start the time dependent method
okay so now in the third part of my talk
i want to
try to explain what kind of analysis we
can do on our network and
what this kind of uh and so how can we
go beyond
beyond a quantitative analysis of our
network so
one thing that we can do i mean so we
did several of these things uh
in in our paper but i'm just going to
present two of them now
the one thing you can do is turn minimum
models on data to understand the bezel
and performance on the input data
and i think that's something you know
that yeah i'm not going to say every
machine learning paper
but i think you know it's very useful in
general
and and really gives a good sense of you
know how much performance you're
actually obtaining
so in this case you know what that could
mean would be you know trying a simple
linear regression on just you know
counting the neighbors at a distance
and you can go you know somewhat far
with that uh so
it's it's actually you know it's giving
some decent correlation
another thing you can do is uh so modify
the inputs and simplify them and see you
know whether the performance
isn't and if you see that some part of
the input makes the performance proper
logic and you can say that this part is
important for protection of the model
and
you could extract that this part is you
know relevant to understand the physics
of the model
you can train variation of the model
with architecture and different hyper
parameters and again try to identify
which parts are critical
and the last thing you can do is take a
pre-trained model so on some inputs and
and fix it
and then modify the inputs and see how
the prediction changes
uh and have some kind of silence
analysis so i'm going to present things
about these two um
the second and the fourth in the end of
this talk
so on the first one um on ablations to
this
so this is the same curve as i showed
before i'm only here i'm just showing
the baseline method of the svm and
normated in blue where we use all the
features and then we try to remove
uh some of the features from the input
and retrain the model and see what the
performance would drop
and so the first thing we did is remove
the vectors and substitute them with
distances so instead of filling a 3d
vectors between two items you just hit
the distance
and so what you can see is that for the
very short times you have a drop in
performance and again
that's not surprising because if you
want to predict dynamics on very short
times
and since we know how network does that
very well um
you know this is showing network is
actually leveraging some geometrical
information
about the angles between particles and
his and his needs to have that to get to
the optimal performance
but what you can see is that as soon as
you increase the time scale a bit more
and in particular when you start to
reach
it's not trivially plastic regime that
we are interested in then you don't need
this vector information anymore
um there are two interpolation to that
one is that
you know those are not um relevant
um for the physics so that you could
have a simplified model of the physics
that would just be described in terms of
distances
another interpretation is that all
network is just not powerful enough to
leverage that and so just drops
information but you it could in theory
you know do better
by basing all the features uh a small
caveat here is also that there's a saudi
hypothesis which would be that
you know it's reconstructed the young
girls from the distances
because of the way we define the edges
that's you know possible for the network
to some extent
i i don't think it's doing that but
that's the third option
um and then we had a yeah
we had another interesting baseline
which is the screen cover we removed
everything so then we don't fit the
distance anymore we just have a graph
and so all we have is all the network
has as an input is we know which node is
connected is
at under a certain threshold to it to
any other node
which defines a connectivity graph and
uh you can do surprisingly well with
that
uh so you know as the uh at very long
time so you you don't do much
uh but as you increase the time scale
you you start to do better and
this is very consistent with the picture
where the the dynamics become more
diffusive and so
if the dynamics becomes more about the
density uh rather than you know the
exact details of the distance
then you would expect this kind of a
picture
and you can do better if you if you
modify the threshold so if you take a
smaller threshold of course you can you
you are more fine-grained in terms of
the estimation of these densities
and you can actually you know uh do
better than the previous you know
machine learning instead of dr
even into single gym with you know such
a simple description
um and then the second part of analysis
we did so now we are taking a trend
model and we're just going to modify the
input
uh so we've returned this network and um
and it's making up
so once you've pretended you can apply
to any input of course
and so what we're going to do is we take
a a particular node
so we fix a node and we're going to look
at the prediction for this one so the
central node is
on this picture um and
we are going to uh remove all the notes
at a distance greater than d
uh from this node so what the network
would need to take as an input
what it sees during training when it's
trained is
all the nodes up to a certain uh
distance d and this distance d is
defined by the
you know the threshold that we use times
the number of times you apply the
network
as i explained earlier every time you
apply the network you probably get
information you know one edge
away and so you can you can compute how
many uh like what's what's the input
which is required for the prediction of
the sensor
and so we just remove some of this input
and we want to see how does this change
um and um so the thinking here is that
if you understand how the network is
doing so the network
um you can think of the prediction uh on
the
on the on the central node that's coming
from the prediction under on the nodes
just
one edge away which themselves have had
the embeddings updated based on the on
the nodes you know two edges away from
the central node and so on and so forth
and so the question here is really you
know how much does the prediction for
the central depend on the things that
are far away
versus how much does it just depend on
the nearest neighbors and information
that comes from further is just washed
out
right and these two things could happen
the network could just be using
the information which is coming from
very close and and any other correlation
would disappear or it could be
propagating information at a further
distance
and so this is uh what we see uh so
this is a different temperature i think
this slide is again a bit
let's look just at the bottom right
there which is the lowest temperature
and the green curves at a very short
time so what you see here is on the very
short time you can remove things you
know
um and on the x-axis you have the number
of shells that you are considering so
shells being you know many edges away
you keep atoms
and the the y-axis is the performance
the higher the better
so what you see on the green curve uh
for the very short time is that you know
as soon as you have two shades of atoms
and the performance is very good in
plateaus you don't get you don't you
don't gain anything by adding more
shells and you don't lose
actually that much even by going to one
chain which is showing that the network
in that case
can't just rely on the very immediate
neighborhood of a particle to make a
prediction
which is very consistent of course with
a short time you know behavior where the
vertical is going to move around and
maybe
bump into its neighbors once and that's
all so it doesn't need to know anything
about the neighbors you know three hops
away
um and what we see on the on the and
then the other
two curves so the orange one and the
blue one at longer time scale so the
blue one is this very long time
regime the diffusive regime and the
orange one is in this interesting
glassy regime and there you see that you
know you have a drop in performance
as you um if you just consider france on
the first child and you don't do any any
predict any good
prediction so it doesn't help you to
know how close you are from your
neighbors because at this time scale
that's not
you know that's not relevant anymore
it's all about these things more global
information in terms of information that
comes from further away
and you need you know you're starting at
least three chances to do a good
prediction in the diffusivity and in the
glassy regime
the crop is even uh like remains slower
for longer and so you you know the
performance keeps improving
until you reconsider particles from far
away
so that was a pretty drastic experiment
because we were removing a lot of
particles but we were removing all the
particles
after a certain distance so more
infinitesimal change you can do
is to to change the the features of the
graph at a certain distance so we keep
all the particles the same
and we look again we look at at the same
distance d or
number of hsd from the central particle
and we are going to extend all the edges
between the
the the the index id and the next gen
so you know the idea is to push all the
particles a little bit further away at a
given distance
and we want to see whether this affects
the prediction or not and again there
are two possibilities
if the network is making a prediction
based on very local features
and doesn't propagate information far
away then that shouldn't change the
results
but if the network needs to know about
things that happen far away then that
will change the results
and this is you know in terms of physics
this is similar to a susceptibility
because you're looking at the
uh infinitesimal change in a in a
country in a quantity at a given
location based on the change of the
of the system at another location so the
difference maybe with the usual
susceptibility
is that it's not a two-point
susceptibility but you're looking at you
know um
some kind of point-to-set correlation
where a full set of atoms change and a
full set of distance are slightly
increased and you look at the response
in one point
um and what you can see on this one so
this one
has sweet temperatures let's start maybe
with the lowest temperatures to the
temperature
we have the thing which is the most um
which has the
the most classy behaviors on the bottom
right again
and uh what you see here is uh the
response of the system
on the y-axis as a function of where you
apply the dispensation
so on the x-axis from a closest shell to
like
shells further away the green curve
again is the very short time prediction
and there you see the same as before
uh if you modify things you know beyond
the second channel doesn't change the
results at all so you can do this
modification the networks just ignores
it because this information is
completely
washed out as you apply the network
several times
uh what's interesting there is the
orange cup which is the one in the
glacier regime
where you have this peak uh in the in
the change when you go to three
four shells away and so this is showing
that the network you know even if you do
a small change
between the third and fourth chain this
is going to impact the prediction at the
central
particle so this information is going to
be propagated by the network it's not
going to be
uh um like the departure is not going to
decrease it's not the perturbative
change it's going to to stay there and
to be propagated and up to up to the the
central particle
um and this is more this effect is more
pronounced
uh for this glassy regime that's for the
longer time scan so the blue time scale
is a diffusive regime
so on this curve really you go from
green to orange to blue right so you
have this kind of peak
in the correlation uh when you are in
this intermediate timescale
and then we looked at this so this was
our lowest temperature but we also
looked at higher temperatures to see how
would the effect change
and you can see that at very high
temperature i mean high temperature on
the
top left the effect is far less
pronounced and
you have a little bit but almost nothing
and it increases as you as you decrease
temperature
and this is of course uh so why are we
doing that
so this is one way in which you could
you know try to define a correlation
length
and you know what what this is hinting
towards is that you know
i mean this is suggesting that it could
be a correlation length you know around
the distance corresponding to three or
four shells in the in this instance
and that this correlation and so and
this correlation length you know would
appear as you lower the temperature and
then
you know what would be interesting is to
study how this correlation length varies
as the temperature is decreased uh
in our case we yeah we didn't really go
beyond that because
uh we i mean we start to have final size
effect so that was one reason ecosystem
is uh is concerned in the box so you um
you know you can't do a
like we are like this correlation let's
say starting to be at the order of you
know
half the box length so you can't exclude
you know fine uh boundary conditions
effects and and so on
uh and you would want to a lower
temperature as well and uh to have a
greater range of temperatures to really
be able to make to do a plot
uh this collection as a function of the
temperature but this is a good
indication that there might be something
there that the network would be picking
up basically
so the idea there is that you know there
is maybe as i said if you come back to
the question in the beginning
where um you know we know that dynamics
gets much slower
but we don't know how this relates to
the structure and we you know we don't
know how to define a correlation link
that
captures that we don't know what to
measure on the structures to explain the
difference
in in dynamics and one way to look at
this result would be to say that maybe
this network could be starting to you
know um
[Music]
to extract something from the structure
that explain the dynamics and that you
can
you know this isn't this reason this is
pretty structure-based now it's it's
based on the network and that's just
gets you know one single time input
and so maybe the network is reading from
this input something about the
correlation x maybe
it's the combination it does is
implicitly extracting correction links
conclusions uh i think have explained
why graph networks were well suited for
the modeling of particle systems and one
thing to emphasize here is that we
didn't know directly a simulator
because we are learning very far in the
future right the time skills we learn
uh is a time scale repositories have
collided you know thousands of times so
it's so that we learn the details of all
these collisions
and this is also why we are already
we're using the propensity and averaging
of the velocity so we are learning some
consequent version of the simulator if
you wish um which which tells something
about you know the typical dynamics
uh and the fact that we use these graph
networks and destructive models allows
us to get some qualitative insight into
their inner workings
and to correlate with physical
quantities
um another aspect that i've mentioned
here is that our system can generalize
over physical quantities
uh so we've tried to vary temperature
and see you know can you train a model
to give a temperature at a rate
and apply it at another temperature and
we've shown that uh this was indeed
working so there is a range where things
will generalize and as
you lower the temperature generalization
gets better which was also a good sign
because you you have this notion of a
university class of class and so that's
where you want to be
um and so i know something's akin to
apply this to system that are
uh too slow for them to study and yeah
yeah there are some natural systems so
to which you'd want to apply this and go
and go further than what we did uh
and finally what we try to to do with
this work is to show that the machining
can be used not only to make
quantitative predictions
but also to gain some qualitative
understanding of physical systems
and yeah with that i'm going to thank
you for your attention
great thanks a lot well thanks to you
for the nice talk
so we have time for questions if anybody
wants to ask something please
either type it in the chat window or
raise your hand
and then we'll take it from there
okay if there are none then it's my
chance wonderful or peter you have a
question
yes so i um i i very much enjoyed this
talk and it
reminded me of another talk we had in
our seminar last year
on the structure formation in the
large-scale
universe and that was work by
a few people from shirley hall's group
at the flatirons institute
i i wonder if you had seen that work
because it similarly
looks at a box of particles and their
evolution
i guess the particles are much larger
yeah they are sort of
like maybe galaxy size but the ideas of
pursuing the dynamics and the
distribution
of the matter after a fairly long time
intervals maybe somewhat similar
i think they used very different
networks than you used
but i i suspect you know much more about
it than i do so but i
thought i'd raise this as a discussion
topic
yes i think i know what you're talking
about it's it's an interesting workout
so yeah you're right i think they were
using
um i mean i hope i don't say something
wrong i don't remember the work
completely but i
remember they're using some
convolutional networks and i suppose
that's because if i remember they're
working on densities already
so i think there's a question of so we
describe a particular system
so that's why we use this kind of you
know network that operates on objects
but if you have more objects and
depending on the scale you look at you
could also look at density so we could
you know make our system continuous
by dividing our box into um you know
subunits and compute the average density
in each subunit and try to learn on this
and i think that's what this other work
that you're mentioning is doing if i
remember
so they they
use units um which is
a convolutional network with a bit of a
feedback i think
and um they do sort of track them
more or less as particles so one of the
beautiful things is that it was quite
difficult for them to
protect uh project the um predicted
straight motion
but the the rotation of these large
structures around each other was
captured very well
by the model and if i remember the model
is learning
a correction on some simpler model of
the dynamics right
correct the it it learns on top of this
straight motion because the straight
motion was difficult to
to put in the model and so it it i think
that's called the zelda witch or so
model and then they they model the
refinement of that that includes the
rotations
uh due to gravitational forces yeah it
just has a superficial similarity
and also the problem scale is similar i
think they were talking about exactly
the same
number of particles in a in a box that
that you described
so i think one one thing one
question about our work is that we don't
predict that uh so it's we're not really
learning a simulator because we don't
we go from this um you know we go from
this particle to this propensity which
is some average
notion of where is the particle going to
be in the future
but it doesn't allow you to sample a
configuration in the future what we do
right so you get some you know
average position uh
but well yeah so and i think one
interesting question is whether
or not there is a way to go back from
this you know average positions through
real configuration
so could you could we reconstruct a
configuration that looks you know
reasonable
uh in some extent that has a
you know the right priority mass under
the boltzmann distribution or
from this average prediction of dynamics
i think that would be that's
something i have been thinking about
which i think is difficult
um because in okay i think it's hard to
realize the consent so you know where
each particles you know wants to be but
when you start
when you try to reconstruct you start to
put particles you know
uh nearby and then you know you start
have constraining oh you have too much
materials close together like the energy
is very high
and it's very hard to reserve this
constraint which i think comes back to
the the
you know the interesting difficulty of
this program which is that it's a very
constrained physics problem
where um yeah
well but i think that's a that's another
interesting difference between these
works right
well as i understand it that system you
can unroll it many times in the future
so if they've learned something that
goes from their initial time to the
final time
they could have played a second time and
you know go further in the future
if i understood the work correctly why
not because we cannot do that
because we don't get a configuration we
get some average over you know the
velocities and some
average configuration if you want
maybe let me latch on to that point so
you said before that you
train your model to predict the
propensity at some future distant time
and and in a sense you're completely
sidestepping the entire time evolution
as it occurs right
so do you have some do you have some so
you have some intuition of what the
model internally is doing like when you
apply it
does it have some analog of what would
normally be called a time evolution or
is there really the
possibility that you can predict the
propensity without
looking at it you know as an evolution
through time but you you know directly
have the answer in a sense
yeah uh yeah i think i think that's a
yeah that's a very
good question and i can't answer with
more than you know
my way to think about this and
yeah my thing is that the system is not
doing the time evolution but that's just
you know i don't have any any uh
evidence for that
uh except that you know maybe one
evidence would be to say that the fact
that the system get
gets the same performance when you just
feed the distances instead of feeling it
you know
the vectors and also remember that the
system never sees the velocity so it's
always going to predict something which
is average over the initial velocities
so you could argue that the system might
be doing this average you know
implicitly
the system could potentially um you know
reconstruct all of this
uh um and perfect you know i mean
having the system you know was large
enough you could imagine it's something
velocities
or it's you know creating an array
velocities and then
doing the dynamics for this velocities
and averaging the output and would be
doing the dynamics implicitly but i
think that you know our dividend is not
going
in this direction it's really natural to
think that the system is doing something
different
and i think that's where you know
there's this nice duality and then when
you apply the graph network several
times
you can think of it as doing the dynamic
i mean one way to think of this
um distributed application is that it's
doing the dynamics and you're going
further in time so each time you apply
to you go from one time step to the next
but another one another way to think
about this is that you're doing some
concern propagation for instance you
could think that network is doing
something about you know reasoning about
mobility
and whether you are it particularly
stuck or not in its position
and that when you play it several times
you do an update on this constraint
right so you could think about a rule
like you know i'm stuck if all my
neighbors are stuck
or something like that and then you
would apply that right and then and that
would converge to something
and i mean that's one of the nice things
with the graph network is that because
we apply the center trap several times
you can see that as
a time evolution or you can see that as
a sort of fixed point equation where you
converge
yeah i see thanks okay there's a
question by who am
in the chat do you want to type it in or
do you want to okay
i'll i'll say it hi okay so what i was
wondering whether
you show these pictures of dynamic
heterogeneity
from one of our papers actually and the
key there is that
you have these blue and red that you
showed and that's
you have particles which are fast and
ones which are slow
yeah so does your network perform
better on the fast one or the slow ones
when it predicts
um good question
uh
yeah that's a good question i'm trying
to remember
whether i don't remember
us doing this analysis although that's
yeah that's not the economies you'd want
to do i don't remember i mean one thing
to note is that the network
because of the weights trend and so our
network is trained with
you know a standard l2 less on the
propensities and so it
has a prior for predicting things close
to the mean so the details
of the distribution are pretty uh so
yeah i can't really show that i don't
know if i'm still presenting
i don't have this picture actually but
yeah well what you would see is that you
know
one thing to note is that the when the
correlation is good you know
the extreme events tend to be um the
network will tend to to uh to not
capture completely detail of the
distribution it would tend to put in its
prediction closer to the mean that they
should be
uh which is why you know but
which is why i mean when you look at the
correlation you don't you don't really
see that but
but in terms of the error yeah that's a
good question i don't think we have an
answer to
that i don't think there was a very
clear trend i think when we
tried to look at this we didn't see you
know anything striking
but there could be something and and
because i would have expected that it
should work better with what slow you
have these low clusters the blues
regions in that in those pictures and
um so the particles haven't really moved
from where they were before
so your network has not deformed because
one thing that would happen
on long times is that the structure that
you started from the connectivity
structure you started from
over long times you know these systems
are ergotic right so
um the structure that you get much much
later is so different
but it has to be a limit to how long you
know how long you can predict for
is is that's more or less correct as a
statement
yes it is uh but i think the what
happens is that the
um the network is looking sufficiently
far
you know the network is enrolled we
weren't running a network server
seven times in the plots i was showing
so the network can capture information
which comes from
relatively far away and
so i believe that the regime whether the
graph would be you know
too different for the network to make a
good prediction would probably come
you know pre after the times that we
studied uh so
i mean that could be an issue that's
correct but yeah
but i don't think on a truck would
necessarily be hitting that
uh i mean again if you if you take the
view that the network is doing some
iterative computation you could imagine
that network is
you know capable of propagating
some updated information about where
each particle is and so
you know that i mean i guess i'm saying
that that's not necessarily
that's something that the network could
potentially be dealing with i think
what's happening i think in our case
it's probably something which is
you know of fairly low effects that
doesn't necessarily
empty the results on the time scale that
we look at
great thanks
thanks for the question okay anything
else
any more questions if not
then i think i should say
thank you again on behalf of everybody
and on behalf of those people who have
asked questions it was a great talk i've
learned quite a bit
so thanks a lot to you victor and
i think see you next week yeah thanks
for organizing
bye bye